she was admitted to hospital and rapidly
went downhill
once admitted on oxygen
um then various progressively
more severe stages ventilators
and eventually um it was becoming
sort of a life-threatening situation for
her and her
unborn baby imagine being told to
prepare for the worst
a doctor tells you that your pregnant
partner and the unborn baby inside her
are unlikely to survive that's what
tommy larkins was told
he was terrifying most terrifying
thing i've been through in my life it
was awful
um to potentially lose the pair of them
on the same night was was really bad
really bad
elsa became critically ill with covert
19
just after christmas
heavily pregnant she was rushed to
kingston hospital
her health deteriorated quickly and she
was moved to one of the hospital's two
intensive care units here
she was put into a coma and intubated
elsa spent two weeks in intensive care
on this ward and with a
desperately sick mother there are always
concerns
about the unborn child elsa was one of
the unit's youngest
patients at just 34 she
had no underlying health conditions but
she was
carrying a baby being
told potentially to say your last
goodbyes
to you to your other half and to your
baby
as well he's you know your world comes
crashing down
is that possible how long you are sick
for
two weeks from today difficult
conversations
are happening all the time okay have you
got any beds yet
no not yet alison's just gone to the
office to sort it out
a relentless flood of sick patients
needing expert care okay
so the answer is please don't let them
take any staff from you without going
through me yeah
because i've been fighting it never
stops
i've been here for about half an hour
every time i've seen you you're on the
phone
people are coming up to you it's so busy
very constant and things like that you
don't imagine you don't even think about
the number of medicines we need we don't
have enough cupboard space
we don't have enough space for the
equipment to store it
how long seriously do you think you
carry on at this point
um i think we're on our knees we're all
being very trying to be very positive
i have staff who phone up in tears they
can't come into the building so we have
to send another nurse out to pick them
up
i think once they're here it's not so
bad it's the thought
of how am i going to cope looking after
that many patients
it's difficult for staff patients
and loved ones tommy broke the news to
his girls
melissa and alba it's a potential that
mummy's on a knife edge
well i'm pretty sure she i'm sure she's
going to be okay she's a fighter
on january the 5th the decision was
taken to deliver elsa and tommy's baby
by emergency c-section a full
two months before the baby was due
absolutely petrified uh
you know the baby it was during march
the the second week of march you know
to be to have an emergency c-section
uh a baby potentially born with covid
um
it was it was awful awful it was all
very dark
it was all quite quite a horrible place
to be
[Music]
one of the critical care nurses who
cared for elsa
thankfully there's not we haven't seen
many pregnant ladies
but elsa was particularly sick when she
came in um
she was really struggling to breathe i
think the difficulty with that was the
fact that she was
heavily pregnant um the big bump that
she had due to the pregnancy was
obviously pushing on the bottom of her
lungs
elsa is not in intensive care anymore
the operation has been a success
hello mr bray
and this is their new baby
a little girl elsa and tommy's daughter
weighs just 1.4 kilograms and needed
life support
in those first few critical weeks
day by day hour by hour
that she again she had ups and downs
tommy has been allowed to visit his
daughter and partner
on compassionate grounds after seeing
her so weak and poorly
in an incubator um to
to holding a a couple of days ago
it was amazing amazing best feeling
to come through and see that lightly
under the tunnel
um it was was amazing and
we've still got a little way to go still
not out of the woods
elsa has yet to meet her beautiful
tiny fragile daughter it could be weeks
before all three
are home together the pandemic baby who
survived
against all odds has a name
hello she's called florence
a tribute to the nurses and doctors
who saved her and her mother's life
ashish joshi sky news
at kingston hospital